are you just focused on Fantastic Four
this year do you think you could be
directing something else I don't think
so you know I'm still finishing up the
Godzilla project you were mentioning um
we're in post on that and have a few
more months on that
um but Fantastic Four is pretty much my
life until Valentine's Day of 2025. I
mean it's very tough to have to spend
that much time with those characters
right
um so listen a lot of people online have
been uh talking about rumors with
casting and all this BS
um are you casting right now or what can
you tease people in fact of like where
you're at in the pre-production of FF
um all the casting stuff that you see
here is just rumors we we are you know
early in our process there
um uh we have nothing to announce right
now and uh and certainly when we do
we'll let you know when do you actually
because you have a release date
um do you have the I look do you know
when you might start filming like have
you sort of mapped out the schedule yeah
early next year